Hi.
I've loved you
my whole life.
One way or another.
Well, well, well.
Prodigal son.
You're the prodigal one.
I'm just the black sheep.
Where were you?
In New York.
Upstate New York.
I guessed that.
I mean, when you...
ran away,
it was a subject
of a lot of debate.
Many people had theories
and most of them
were Hollywood, but...
that was one of my guesses.
Why?
Covered bridges...
-You remember that?
-Mm-hmm.
Told you that
like half our lives ago.
Are you really walking by
without saying hi?
Should get going,
I don't want to keep
my parents waiting.
Some things never change.
I remember
a 15-year-old Riley
sneaking out
of my bedroom window
trying to make curfew.
I did my fearless
moral inventory
and I found out that...
man, I'm a coward.
Don't do that.
Don't talk about yourself
like that.
If anyone else
talked about you like that,
I'd...
What?
Kick their ass.
-Oh, yeah?
-Yeah.
-Kick their ass?
-I'd kick it.
Just like this. Oh!
That was actually
my thigh, so...
-So I'd kick their thighs?
-Yeah.
I have this, um...
dream.
This recurring dream
about it since I was inside.
I'm floating out
in the middle of the bay,
in the middle of the waters.
Grey water, morning water.
And the more
I have that dream,
the more I just know
that it's not
in the cards for me.
I'm not getting off
this island.
I know it.
And at night,
no matter what I might
let myself hope or...
I know it.
But you...
you do anyway.
You always could
do anything.
Hi.
I had that dream again
last night.
The one on the water?
Yeah. Just like always.
Waiting on the sun.
But this time...
you're there too.
What do you think
that means?
You could come back
tonight, maybe.
I can do that.
Where the hell
have you been?
I have been calling you
all day!
-I'm sorry.
-Don't do that.
Where were you?
Do you remember a few days
before you left town?
Crawled in my window,
woke me up,
scared the shit out of me.
You wanted
to take a boat out,
wouldn’t take no
for an answer,
so we grabbed a row boat
and rowed out.
Far.
Smoked a pack of cigarettes,
watched the sun come up.
Will you do that
with me now...
and go for a ride?
So, you've told me
that story,
you...
brought me out here,
have brought us out here
where there is nowhere
for me to go.
I brought you out here,
so I'd have nowhere to go.
I'm not as strong as you.
I never was.
I knew you wouldn't believe
any of this unless you saw.
I want you...
to run.
But I believe
you're going to row back
and do everything you can
to try save them.
I'm just so sorry
you have to see this.
I love you, Erin Greene.
I've loved you
my whole life.
One way or another...
I love you too.
I did my best.
So, what do you think
happens when we die, Erin?
Speaking for myself?
The body stops,
a cell at a time,
but the brain keeps firing
those neurons.
Little lightning bolts
like fireworks inside
and I thought I'd despair
or feel afraid,
but I don't feel
any of that.
None of it.
Because I'm too busy...
too busy in this moment
remembering.
And of course...
I remember
that every atom in my body
was forged in a star.
This matter, this body,
is mostly
just empty space, after all,
and solid matter,
it's just energy
vibrating very slowly
and there is no me.
There never was.
The electrons of my body
mingle and dance
with the electrons
of the ground below me
and the air.
I'm longer breathing.
And I remember...
there is no point
where any of that ends
and I begin.
We are the cosmos
dreaming of itself.
It's simply a dream
that I think is my life.
Every time.
But I'll forget this,
I always do.
I always forget my dreams.